good morning Hank it's Tuesday my son
Henry doesn't watch a lot of television
although he does enjoy Uncle Hanks space
videos but I recently watched 12 of the
most popular programs for toddlers to
understand what he might be watching and
Hank because I remember that you were a
big fan of the show Blue's Clues when
you were in college I come to you today
with an introduction to contemporary
children's television so I can general
watching children's television is a dark
and surreal descent into madness where
the characters on the screen talk
directly to you so for example at the
end of every episode of Dora the
Explorer she'll be like what was your
favorite part and I'll be like well the
weirdest part was the part where you and
your pet jaguar went camping with
nothing but a flashlight and some snacks
and she'll say I liked that part too and
I'll be like no I didn't like it Dora I
thought it was weird you're a toddler
you should be inside also Hank in the
world of contemporary children's
television we've apparently abandoned
child labor laws like take for example
the Dora the Explorer spin-off Diego he
goes like a four-year-old who's been
inexplicably promoted to some kind of
park ranger that allows him to go around
the world and save animals apparently
there are a lot of animals in distress
because like Wonder Pets which is about
an operatic gerbil he saves animals in
need as do the kids on little einsteins
a show about kids who fly around in a
rocket called
rocket but of course there are also
people in need specifically child actors
and for those child actors we have
Special Agent Oso and Oso special agent
panda who travels around the world
helping child actors learn to do things
like tie their shoes Team Umizoomi is
also in the child actor assistance
business but they specialize in math
which can be a little bit humiliating
because they'll be like hey do you know
what shape this is I'll be like mmm
octahedron and they'll say that's right
it's a dodecahedron and I will feel the
shame Hank there are also lots of shows
about kids who go into their backyards
and have really compelling
hallucinations like The Cat in the Hat
and The Backyardigans and Phineas and
Ferb which by the way is the best
television program I have ever seen for
children or adults in fact not to brag
but I own a Perry the Platypus Swindon
Town suitably poopers doll it airs on
the Disney Channel which also contains
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse the first time I
saw a Mickey Mouse Clubhouse I was like
this is amazing that's a television
program with no advertisements and then
I realized the television program is the
advertisement what else oh yeah there's
the hot slice of crazy known as Yo Gabba
Gabba Hank I don't know what Yo Gabba
Gabba is about but I do know that it
contains more good music than MTV like I
give you any hear this
ins or Weezer or Weird Al or mos def on
TV you have to watch Yo Gabba Gabba and
then you have the wildly popular Niihau
kai-lan a show that I'm surprised right
wing commentators haven't gotten upset
about given how they felt about the
Teletubbies I mean
Nihao kai-lan basically teaches American
children like the importance of
Confucian filial piety a smattering of
Mandarin Chinese words and the very
dangerous lesson that the best way to
solve your problems is by collaborating
with the tiger
whereas in America we know that the best
way to solve our problems is by not
collaborating at all and lastly Hank
there are currently two different shows
on television about octopuses who
inexplicably do not need water to
survive
there's the charming Oswald and the
terrifying Octonauts so the Octonauts
look at the bottom of the ocean and some
kind of pressurized contraption and
their leader appears to be this monocled
octopus and then sometimes valve animals
in distress they travel around in this
anglerfish which is awesome except the
angler fish has a male voice and we all
know that is a female anglerfish because
if it were a male it would be just a
sperm producing parasite on her side
more importantly Hank what's up with the
octopus symbol that's on their hats and
their uniforms and their coffee mugs has
their monocle octopus cohort created
some kind of cult of personality where
they worship Him as Dear Leader and why
is there a children's television program
celebrating this weird underwater cult I
think that's not even to mention Bubble
Guppies a show in which little mermaids
and murder dudes despite living
underwater are able to have campfires no
wonder our science scores are so low so
ain't those are my conclusions from a
week of watching children's TV don't
forget to be awesome and I will see you
on Friday